welcome to cloud on air a live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Kevin Ford and
today I'll be talking about API security
you can ask questions any time on the
platform and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them
so let's get started so we had a lot to
cover today but we're gonna be looking
at an overview of the Appaji edge
platform which is Google clouds API
management solution and we'll talk
specifically a lot about API security
and the things you need to consider as
an API provider then I'll take you on a
deep dive into Apogee sense which is a
feature of the platform that provides
bot detection and behavior based
detection and then we'll go on to a demo
of that particular feature and then
we'll move into QA so first let's look
at a high-level overview of a PG edge as
a platform and then we'll dive into some
security features so one thing that we
see as a repeated pattern of success
when we work with customers is taking an
outside-in approach with their API so
traditionally a lot of customers
traditionally and IT shops
think of api's as an exposure problem
you know build build the API and
consumers will come and use it and
everything will be you know
straightforward and that doesn't always
happen what we find is a much more
successful programs end up thinking
about how to deliver that experience to
the user so who do we need to enable
here in this in this slide you see the
developer this is the developer building
your your systems of engagement building
your mobile applications your web
applications you need to enable them to
have with it with a great API that's
consistent and easy to use so they can
build those experience and iterate on
them very quickly and you do that with
an API platform that offers features for
your API team to move very rapidly and
respond to the needs of that developer
so we're gonna focus on
in in the opposite platform helping with
exposure but with a deeper focus on
consume ability and that means just a
great developer experience overall so
this is a high-level look at the
capabilities of platform it's one single
unified platform with a single
experience for your users but it can be
thought of as being in three conceptual
parts so API services hosts your runtime
and that manages all your API traffic
that's where you would apply all the API
features and policies like traffic
management and security that we'll get
into developer services is where you
host a portal as a as a primary a
feature and then that enables all of the
other experiences that the consuming
developer will have when they interact
with your api program and then analytics
services to give you the ability to
measure the program from end to end
management services really is the
foundation on which all of them are
built so first API services here you can
see a super high-level overview that
shows where the the platform sits and
the apogee edge runtime sits in between
your API consumers and your back-end
systems and this facade pattern allows
you to extract or abstract a lot of the
cross-cutting concerns that you would
typically build it be building into your
back-end services things like security
throttling managing SLA with particular
clients all of these types of things
that you have to do for all of your API
consumers you move those into the
platform and then that frees up your
service developers to focus on building
services that are related related to
their domain expertise and they don't
have to worry about implementing all
those cross-cutting concerns
so now moving on to developer services
at the heart of developer services is a
developer portal and this is what you
see if you go to any API provider and
you want to consume their API if you go
to Google's developer portal you'll see
a listing of all the api's on offer
you'll have the ability to try them out
you can kick the tires you can see
descriptions of what it requires to
interact with the API s and what they
can do all of these things make it very
easy for you to consume our API s and
you should be thinking the same way
about your own API is think of them as
products and you're marketing these
products to developers who are going to
consume them and especially in the case
where there are alternatives you need to
make that a really good experience for
those developers so that they can their
time - first response is very short
often measured in seconds so as an API
consumer if I go to a portal of an API
provider
I can't within a very small number of
minutes get a successful response and
try it out hopefully in a live trial
situation then I'll move on somewhere
else so having out worse that
world-class developer experience is
really important additionally in the
developer services we host things inside
your portal like a forum blogs we can
hold we can host SDKs all the typical
things that API consumers expect to help
them leverage your api's and be
successful
and then finally analytic services so
you've built out your api's they're
being consumed hopefully by a lot of
developers both internal and external so
how do you measure the success of your
program how do you know which api's are
experiencing more than expect greater
than expected latency are there high
error rates for particular API is that a
problem with your API your API
documentation your back-end or is it an
issue with the client so with Apogee
analytics we provide you insights all
the way from the client consuming app to
your back-end service so you can see
everything along the entire chain and be
able to evaluate and make business
decisions about which API is to promote
which api's might need work and as well
as operational insights for working on
performance and these kinds of things so
every year Apogee hosts an API
conference where we share our thought
leadership on the API landscape and API
space and we have business and technical
tracks and we actually started this this
years in Sunnyvale a couple months ago
and coincidentally today we're wrapping
up the world tour in Chicago but on our
technical track we're always talking
about the aspects of an API program that
make us successful when you look at the
actual API a lot of the things that make
them successful like I mentioned before
making them easily consumable by
developers are things like having a
standard consistent interface and you
get that by applying that facade and not
leaving the interface up to each
individual service developer the fact
that there's a consistent resource model
to code against all these things that
make API is easy use also make them very
easy to use by attackers who want to
exploit vulnerabilities in your backends
so what kind of tools do you have if
you're leveraging Apogee in order to
combat some of these attacks so this
picture shows an end-to-end view of the
types of features of the kinds of
features we have in place to help
protect your your api's starting at the
client we have the ability to to
leverage TLS of course one-way or
two-way TLS between client the client
apps and Appaji itself we have oo auth
policies to enable a auth protection API
key policies JWT policies all
out-of-the-box I'm not going to get into
all this and read this whole slide
there's a lot of features but at the
proxy level we have similarly we have
access control o auth we protect the
backend as well with TLS IP whitelisting
and then the platform itself has full
role based access control both in the
platform for your organization's users
as well as in the developer portal so
when a consumer comes they see the right
API products the right AP is the right
level of access that you want them to
see and you may have a different view
for your internal organism the
developers internal your to your
organization versus external third
parties so all of that end-to-end is all
done through configuration there's no
code this is configuring features or
drag-and-drop with policies to do all
this dis enforcement so there are lots
of attacks and we you know we hear about
these all the time there was a pretty
bad breach just about two weeks ago
where major social network you know
ended up allowing the harvesting of
hundreds of millions of user accounts so
that's one that's an attack that falls
into one of the major two categories we
see and there are more categories in
this but the vast majority of them go
into account takeover type attacks and
scraping attacks so the one I was just
discussing is a scraping attack where a
vulnerability which allowed more access
to more resources than was intended by
the platform
allowed a malicious application to
scrape far more data out and then retain
that data and use it for its own
purposes so there all these attacks are
things that you need to be concerned
with and they're all things that we're
seeing across a broad range of our
customers very few of our customers that
we've evaluated and worked with have not
seen a large number of these attacks
occurring live on their api's so this
this is a quick graphic here to sort of
demonstrate the couple of the different
kinds of attacks and first we're all
familiar with with denial of service
attacks and as a GCP customer you're
already leveraging a massive massive
data center bisection bandwidth in
excess of a thousand terabytes per
second so from a DOS perspective you're
being protected by a cloud provider
that's able to absorb an immense amount
of traffic but there are other kinds of
attacks so if you look at here we've got
the ability to do volume based and
Regeneron known bad ISPs or IPs and that
will block a lot of the that will block
your dos attacks but a lot of things
will still get through because these are
these malicious BOTS creators know how
to stay kind of under the radar they
know that if they send millions of
requests a minute this will be blocked
they also know potentially that you have
because you have a developer portal that
says so that you allow 500 requests an
hour so we see bot writers creating BOTS
that come in at a randomized number of
requests say between 4 and 450 requests
so it looks and blends in with your
normal traffic so it's important that we
have a different way to address these
types of these types of attacks that
look like human traffic so it ends up
that the security model is very
different with api's than it is with
traditional systems before we started
exposing our api's in such a wide way
with external entities so you need
protection those purpose-built
and it's going to separate the bad from
the good traffic both from your good
clients because you need you need to for
a known partner of yours they'll still
make bad bad calls for instance
exceeding a quota we need to block that
for instance issuing a request with an
expired API key you need to block that
but then there are all these bad actors
as well and it's very difficult in that
with those types of calls to distinguish
and that's why we introduced Apogee
sense and this was a response to a lot
of our customers experiencing high
volumes of bot traffic and they came to
us and said this is difficult because we
have set up quotas we've established all
of the right things but they're still
those requests are still coming in and
although they don't always penetrate the
system we can see through our analytics
that they're there they're those
requests are there and they wanted us to
help them address this so how does sense
work so as I mentioned it's it's built
specifically for api's and we've
leveraged the fact that we process
trillions and trillions of API calls to
learn what are the bad behavioral
patterns and this is again not a
deterministic you know this one
particular call is exhibiting this
behavior it's it's more about over time
this particular IP particular ISP set of
AI is set of IPS is exhibiting this
behavior and that is something that we
can detect and it happens in a
closed-loop and it gets smarter and
smarter as you use it and as you apply
rules into the as you feed rules into
the system so sense runs in the
background and it leverages the
analytics data that we're already
collecting so there's very little
overhead we've built the models for
detection based on our understanding of
all of our customers on our cloud
however your data as an individual
Apogee customer is never commingled with
anybody else's data any other customers
data our tenancy model this
allows that but we have leveraged the
fact that we're the largest API
management platform to gain insights
about what kinds of patterns matter and
how to protect against them so a note
also is the patterns I that I mentioned
and we'll look at them in a minute in
the demo we've established the patterns
but they're completely tunable by you so
you start out with sensible defaults and
then you can tune them by you and you
can even introduce your own rules and
patterns so sense operates in two in two
high-level phases there's detection and
protection in detection as I mentioned
the traffic's analyzed in real time and
the alerts when we detect suspicious
behavior and I say Swiss suspicious
we're not we don't know when we detect
something that it is bad traffic but we
know that it matches a pattern that we
suspect might be bad traffic
so we issue alerts immediately to your
administrators and then they come in and
they get a full detailed report that
shows the types of attacks that are
coming in and the behaviors they're
exhibiting you can dig into the logs and
analyze exactly what the requests look
like and that gives your operational
administrators and your security admins
the ability to detect or to start
thinking about how to act on that
traffic so that's phase one and I
mentioned we'll look at some of the
rules but we have rules about unusual
error rates accessing a larger than
expected surface area of your AP is if
you have a catalog for instance in the
retail space it's atypical for a
customer to access 60% of the items in
your catalog that would be a trigger for
a bad behavioral pattern
so the next step is protection so now
we've given you this dashboard and we've
given you alerts to let you know that we
have suspicious activity potentially
happening so you'll see a dashboard
where you can then act on all of these
requests and you can choose and this is
a big differentiator here is you can
choose to allow that traffic to proceed
into the system you can choose to block
it or you can choose to flag it and this
gives you a really flexible way of
handling of handling the traffic and
we'll dive in a little more into what I
mean by that flexible protection but
just a lasts I just want to touch this
drive home this this closed loop so the
closed loop system that we've
implemented does a couple of things one
is because we're leveraging analytics
data that we've already capture anyway
we add very little almost no latency to
request in fact we add no latency at all
to detect we add less than 10
milliseconds of latency when we are
protecting and that's a matter of if you
want to block or allow our flag traffic
so it's a super low latency solution
because it runs in a closed loop offline
with data we're already collecting and a
little more on flexible protection
there's two things we mean when we talk
about flexible protection one is what
you can do what kind of actions can you
take I mentioned that you can block
traffic you can allow traffic or you can
flag traffic so what is flagging what
that means is adding a header for
instance to a request to say maybe I
don't want to block this immediately I'm
aware that this is a bot I'm aware
they're scraping my data but instead of
blocking them so they can go and retool
their BOTS and hit me again I might want
to send them a delayed response I might
want to manipulate the data I can
manipulate the data and the request I
can send them
static pricing data I can dummy the data
up I can remove fields from it there's
all kinds of things I can do to that
data and that's a really powerful tool
because the bot developers are
looking at their responses so sometimes
blocking is the right choice sometimes
you want to do something specific to
handle that in a different kind of way
and allowing is another important aspect
because we have we we allow our partners
to work against our api's in a bot like
way I have many customers who have
partners that write bots to pull down
data on a daily basis so that would
appear to a pudgy sense as a bot but
your security admins can go and allow
all of that traffic for its particular
duration or perpetuity so that that
partner is not his traffic's not blocked
so the other aspect of flexible
protection is configuration or code so
the first the first that I mentioned is
how you act on your traffic and then the
next one the next part is specifically
about the case where you flag traffic as
I mentioned we're going to enricher
request with a header that means once
that request gets into the Apogee
processing runtime you have the ability
to do anything you like to it that means
you can leverage one of the nearly forty
policies and Apogee to do things like
traffic shaping conditional routing and
all of these things are done simply by
configuration it's a policy that you
drag into your API flow you tune the
attributes and it works the other choice
of how you deal with flag traffic is
through code and we have extension
policies that allow you to write
JavaScript Python Java or nodejs if you
want to use extend the capabilities for
handling that flag traffic so it's it
gives you a lot of different flexible
options on how to deal with with these
potential attacks
so I have a graphic here and I want to
talk a little bit sort of the way I
think about API security is it's about
layers of Defense and the best analogy
that comes to mind for me is is this
here if you look at this castle and
imagine for a moment that the walls here
are your API policies your walls are
defining that
oo-oo-oo-oo 2.0 is required to enter all
right so they're gonna block those
requests you've got some throttling
going on because you have this one
defined entry point with a solid door
maybe guards in the gatehouse and it
looks pretty secure difficult to
penetrate but the problem there's a
problem here the problem is all around
the castle are trees and there's limited
visibility so at any moment there could
be many attackers under the tree line
chipping away at that brick wall and
they may never make it through but if
you give them enough time the odds are
that they will so just because you've
got strong walls and a defined entry
point doesn't completely protect you
you need visibility so here's just
here's a different view it's a similar
castle there's a there's a throttling
mechanism that brings traffic into one
entry point with a strong gate you've
got the same walls with the same
protection but they have a moat and
they've cleared out all the trees so you
can see this this API provider can see
for miles as people are attempting to
come in and attack right and that gives
them the ability to figure out how to
respond to them right if it's a friendly
party no worries you might want to block
that party right so it's kind of the way
I think about it it's its layers and
layers of security and the sense feature
that we're talking about a few slides
back is an additional layer beyond the
DOS protection you get in GCP beyond the
full suite of security policies already
offered by Apogee edge to hit to handle
that traffic that looks like human
traffic or looks like
friendly traffic but is not and then of
course protection we mentioned detect
with the visibility helps us with that
and protect so as unfriendlies are
approaching we know exactly how to deal
with them
alright so at this time I'm gonna jump
into a quick demo of Apogee sense to
show you what the dashboards look like
and how you might interact with them
alright ok so what you can see right
here is the sense dashboard and right
now we're on the on the detection the
bot analysis report let me switch into
the rules and show you what those look
like so I mentioned that we have a lot
of rules baked into sense that are
designed and actually were built based
on the trillions of API calls that we
receive too and and our deep experience
working with all of our customers so we
have things like content quota exceeder
Olaf collector I mentioned scraping we
have content scrapers we have guessers I
mean each one of these is combating a
particular type of bot but that
generally fall into a few categories but
let's look at a couple of these so Olaf
the collector and you had a description
here it's a high number of OAuth
sessions but a small number of user
agent families so here you can define
the ranges of what's acceptable or
what's expected behavior now I can
define these rages for that rule and
that rule will simply control with those
new defined parameters when suspicious
activity is highlighted or when activity
would be highlighted as suspicious and
I'd be alerted and the policies are all
similarly configured they have different
levels of attributes for each one and
different minimum minimums and maximums
in their ranges but they all effectively
have follow this pattern where it's an
established set of attributes and you
configure the range that defines
suspicious behavior you also have the
ability to create your own rules if
there are specific attacks that are
relative to you or you feel you want to
investigate a particular area of concern
you can build your own rules as well
the next I can look at the report
detection report as I mentioned again
I'm gonna I'm gonna just to remind the
audience
it's about detect and protect and the
first section which is where we still
are right now is about detection I want
to look at a report of what's going on
in my platform and little issue here
just let me refresh the page
get in the right organization all right
here we go so over here I can see the
the total traffic that's coming into my
system over this particular time range
and I can adjust my time range and I'm
showing all of them I can filter by the
requests that are already defined to be
allowed blocked or flagged or ones that
I have not taken action yet so at this
point I can see that kinds of of
behaviors that sense is detecting its
detect detecting one guesser bought a
login guesser an oauth abuser and an
oauth collector and this is the traffic
from each of those i can directly act
here which allows me to establish to
build a rule a protection rule to
enforce a particular action on these
types of requests in the future i can
dig into the the details of them if i
like i can even look at a list view
which shows particular requests this is
this is a particular IP address it's
activity over the time range and that
we've set and the types of rules that
it's that it's triggering and here i can
also act on it which will create a rule
for me so that's the detection side now
if I look at protection again let's look
at the protection rules that are already
established these are ones that have
already been set based on suspicious
activity that sense has highlighted to
me so these rules have been created I
can add rules I can filter them and you
can see exactly the definition and how
long they're lasting this is a
short-lived rule that'll last for a few
hours this one will always be there
because it's my trusted partner I don't
expect them to change if they change
I'll work with sense to configure the
rule for them but I want my trusted
partner to always come through with
their friendly bot
but I can create a rule and I can block
traffic I can have it expire whenever I
like and I can block by bot reason let's
block all brute guessers and have that
expire in 12 hours
and yes it's active sorry
block brute guessers
so I created that rule and from this
point forward sense will automatically
and instantly enforce this blocking rule
now had I made a flagging rule what
sense would do is add that header that I
can then go modify my Apogee API to
respond to that header in a particular
way so if that's a quick run-through
there's a lot more I could show you of
appaji sense and of course of the entire
Apogee platform but in the time we have
hopefully I covered a sort of the
end-to-end flow of how Apogee sense
works so I'm going to hop back here
all right sorry about that delay so
hopefully this session was informative
hopefully you learned a few things if
you want to learn more there are lots of
ways to do so so first and foremost
Apogee offers a free trial where you get
unlimited use of the platform and you
can spin up an organization which is the
high level Apogee unit of tenancy you
can think of it as your company and you
can spin that up in a matter of seconds
and you can then go ahead and create API
proxies and start proxying your own
services or third-party api's in no time
we have hands-on enablement as well
there's a virtual API GM where it's a
video instruction course where you'll
have an instructor lead you through a
series of labs and workshops that take
you through the end-to-end journey of an
AP API provider and we also offer
on-site API jams where we do the similar
thing but we come to you or invite you
to one of our offices with your team and
then product demo webinars like this one
and others we've got a lot of features
covered and we're going to continue to
cover more features based on the
feedback we get from you all to these
types of sessions
so stay tuned for live QA we'll be back
in less than a minute
you
welcome back so I wanted to do a quick
recap before I jump into the Q&A we
covered Apogee as a platform we talked
about a lot of the API security threats
that we see every day when we're dealing
with customers and this involves
standard API security policy policy type
things such as enforcing oo auth
enforcing your triple a type
authentication as well as traffic
management quota management we talked
about box both good BOTS from trusted
partners as well as malicious BOTS and
then what features an Apogee edge allow
you to address those different concerns
and then we drilled down a little bit
into Apogee sense which is our bot
detection feature and I gave a quick
demo of Apogee sense that shows how you
can detect BOTS flowing through your API
and how you can act on those either
blocking traffic allowing traffic or
flagging traffic for special handling
like like redirecting to a honeypot so
now I want to jump into some questions
that we've gotten throughout the session
and that are coming in
first what is a performance impact of
sense on API traffic so I touched on
this briefly since I mentioned that
sense adds less than 10 milliseconds and
essentially you can think of this as no
impact because the detection is all done
offline and there's zero impact the less
than 10 milliseconds is simply the time
it takes us to block or flag a call
which you would be performing anyway
through an API policy or any type of
enforcement measure so it's it should
feel like no Layton sees added at all to
proxies when you're using sense to your
API is when you're using sense next
question is sense available for private
cloud and private cloud as Apogee sturm
for on-premises we didn't talk about
deployment option
but Apogee can be deployed on the cloud
where it's fully hosted SAS product or
on Prem or we have hybrid options as
well and several other derivatives but
sense is currently only for cloud
customers so on Prem customers are not
able to leverage sense and this has a
lot to do with the technologies we use
to power sense in GCP as well as the the
performance required and the
infrastructure required in order to run
this this kind of a system so next was
asked is sense a separate product or is
it included with Apogee edge so sense is
a feature with an Apogee edge you'll you
can talk about licensing with with your
account team but it's a it's a feature
that's part of the platform and you can
leverage it as long as you're a cloud a
cloud customer and it is restricted to
enterprise customers we have different
tiers pricing tiers so our basic which
are targeting lower volume lower volume
API programs are not able to leverage
sense but all enterprise cloud customers
have the ability to leverage Apogee
sense can this be added can sense be
added at the proxy level and can you
choose which api's flow-through sense so
yes you can detect you can configure the
detection rules to be API proxy specific
so if you only want to detect on your
endpoint you can configure rules to do
that and then protection happens at at
the organization level
finally does sense look across all
customer data to identify malicious
patterns so Apogee sense when we are
building sense and as we continue to
make sense better and smarter we
leverage the breadth of data that we
have across all of our customers on
cloud but that's solely for building the
models there is no that doesn't
participate at all when we're detecting
traffic so it's it's a we are leveraging
our experience working with some of the
most major some of the largest API
providers in the industry to determine
and feed into the models that that sort
of that allow us to surface what are the
behavioral patterns that we should be
concerned with
once those models are defined and we're
ever tuning those models those models
get applied completely within a
particular Appaji organization and I
touched on it but just to to confirm an
organization is a tenant in Appaji so
Apogee is a multi tenant solution and
your company would likely be a single or
possibly more than one organization so
the model is applied to your
organization and the detection and
protection is done solely within the
confines of that organization completely
sandboxed from all other data within
Apogee so your data is never commingled
with any other data all right so that is
that wraps up the questions that we
received that were not already answered
answered individually so I just wanted
to thank you all for your time and and
remind you to stay tuned for the next
session which is get the most out of
your audit logs with these configuration
best practices broadcasting live from
our New York office
you
you